une initiative qui pourrait créer des
emplois dans les banlieue à clichy sous
bois un fast food halal vient d'ouvrir
ses portes
cette création soulève quelques
questions répond elle à une exigence
économique ou est ce le signe d'un repli
communautaire
emmanuel lagarde et clément berthet
l'enseigne annonce la couleur ici la
cuisine se fait à la musulmane mais le
service est à l'américaine chaque détail
rappelle les plus grandes chaînes de
fast-food la différence et dans la
viande conforme aux règles musulmanes
c'est halal
donc ça me permet de goûter un peu plus
de 200 briques jusque là cette famille
était plutôt habitué aux fast-foods
traditionnel signalé n'en mangez du
poisson que l'on peut manger de la
viande est d'ailleurs en continu et
gayon si vous êtes en cuisine sur les
caisses de viande on retrouve deux
labels à votre service c'est la
principale association de certification
halal en france
le restaurant reçoit chaque jour la
visite d'un contrôleur sinon la cité
belge
le soldat américain je travaille aussi
invitera son banquier des branchements
mais derrière le comptoir on peut au
choix forcé le voile ou pas ce nom pour
tunis et pour moi je trouvais pas
travail m'ont donné ma chance
les deux tiers des employés sont
musulmans un peu à l'image du quartier
mais pourtant ici c'est bien l'esprit
d'entreprise qui prime sur le sentiment
communautaire
on ne sait pas de tout mélanger
on fonctionne comme une entreprise
classique et c'est vrai que notre
motivation première aujourd'hui c'est
prendre le maximum de parts de marché y
a pas d'alternative et de défendre omar
se doit mieux se faire connaître
l'équipe pense déjà à la création d'une
chaîne de magasins chaque année en
france depuis sept ans les ventes de
viande halal progresse de 15%